Yes my name is Stephen Wassira, I'm minister
of agriculture for the security of cooperatives
from Tanzania. We're here taking the world
economic forum which is debating so many issues
pertaining to worldly, global issues. And
one letter in which I wish to contribute is
about a turna, a crisis that is going on in
the world is itchins. Not only the developed
countries where they are based are not doing
very well or they need to be restored. But
the need from the developing countries particularly
Africa south of the Sahara. Depend on the
west for our markets, markets for out commodities.
In Tanzania we produce coffee for export,
we produce tea for export, we produce kitchen
knives. But the price for all these commodities
have gone down because of the crisis. So this
is a very serious problem not only to the
developing countries and it is hurting even
more to the developing countries. That is
one, but we live in the world of optimistic,
we are still optimistic that the ithchins
which are being taken by the developing countries
that developed. Particularly this tim nuts
which are being taking to restore the banks
and the other economic enterprise in the west.
We'll eventually bring the economy there.
So we are not losing all but we are still
in hopes.